alle reden vom nächsten winter auch in
brüssel steht nun eigentlich die
politische sommerpause an doch die frage
wie die eu mit weniger oder sogar ganz
ohne gas aus russland über den nächsten
winter kommt lässt keine pause zu der
notfallplan gas den
kommissionspräsidentin von allein in
dieser woche vorgelegt hat der soll die
mitgliedsstaaten dazu bringen die ihren
gaskonsum und 15 prozent zu drosseln und
ihre reserven zu teilen zur not auch per
verordnung dagegen regt sich widerstand
wenn die wohnungen kalt bleiben und die
preise steigen dann droht die einigkeit
europas zu schwinden wie solidarisch
sind die europäer wenn es ums gas geht
wie bereit zu verzichten um putin zu
stoppen wie wirkungsvoll sind die
sanktionen gegen russland und schaden
sie europa womöglich mehr als moskau
sanktionen gegen russland zerreißprobe
für europa das ist der titel unseres
heutigen presse clubs und das sind meine
gäste die ich sehr herzlich begrüße da
ist einmal gesine dornblüth sie ist
freie journalistin und arbeitet unter
anderem für das deutschlandradio stefan
kornelius ist ressortleiter politik bei
der süddeutschen zeitung
sylvia wörgetter ist eu korrespondentin
für die salzburger nachrichten in
brüssel und unsere runde komplett macht
helga schmidt auch sie berichtet aus
brüssel und leitet dort das wdr ndr
hörfunkstudio ja und wie immer streamen
wir unsere sendung auch heute wieder
live in den sozialen medien wenn sie
fragen oder meinungen zu unserem thema
haben nur her damit wir freuen uns ja
seit donnerstag fließt wieder gas aus
russland nach deutschland
seit donnerstag ist aber auch klar dass
die lage völlig unberechenbar bleibt und
vladimir putin den gashahn nach belieben
auf und zudrehen kann putin nutzt gas
als waffe als mittel mit erheblichem
erpressungspotenzial herr cornelius wie
gefährlich ist diese waffe in putins
hand sie ist sehr gefährlich besonders
für deutschland weil deutschland sehr
abhängig ist von diesem gas ist nutzt
deutschland gar nichts von sich aus auf
dieses gas verzichten zu wollen das hat
kein faktor für die kriegsführung und
die finanzierung der russischen
interessen aber putting und das macht
die waffe so gefährlich kann es eben
willkür einsätzen sehr schnell jederzeit
auch zu zeitpunkten die uns besonders
schaden als im herbst dazu kommt dass
die ganze pipeline infrastruktur komplex
ist und schwer zu steuern also wäre es
mit einem enormen dichten problem zu tun
und sind im weitgehend ausgeliefert
diese unberechenbarkeit von blitz die
haben wir am wochenende gerade wieder
gespürt wir haben es gerade in der
tagesschau gesehen da ist am wochenende
und deshalb erschossen worden der hafen
von odessa unmittelbar nachdem russland
und ukraine ein getreide abkommen
geschlossen haben miteinander wie fatal
ist es dass wladimir putin ausgerechnet
dieser mann ist im moment in der hand
hat die europäische energieversorgung
die europäische wirtschaft komplett
durcheinander zu bringen
das ist sehr fatal aber es hängt immer
auch es wird noch fataler dadurch dass
die europäische union und die westlichen
partner und abnehmer in den demokratien
dass auch anerkennen und mit sich machen
lassen dass sie so völlig abhängig sind
oder seien ich möchte ihnen cornelius
nicht ganz zustimmen natürlich hat es
einen aus einer auswirkungen auf
russlands kriegsführung ob wir gas und
in welchem umfang wir gas beziehen denn
es wird immer wieder gesagt russland
würde so ohne weiteres auch andere
abnehmer finden das stimmt nicht ist
also es gibt die these es würde alles
sofort nach china geschafft werden das
ist auch nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
und die frage ist natürlich auch wie
viel geld bezahlt für russisches gas
also da sind schon viele fragezeichen
frau wörter wie schätzen sie die lage
ein wie kritisch ist die worauf zum
beispiel stimmt die österreichische
regierung ihre bürger ein tatsächlich
darauf gas zu drosseln und reserven zu
teilen das ist ein bisschen ein problem
in österreicher dass die österreichische
regierung
signalisiert fürchtet euch nicht wir
machen das schon aber niemand sieht wie
sie es denn machen wollen in österreich
wird neidvoll zum teil nach nach
deutschland geblickt und
fällt der satz ist überspitzt formuliert
so einen wie habe bräuchten wir auch ja
der klartext spricht er den menschen
sagt worauf sie sich einzustellen haben
dazu kommt noch das wenige schritt der
camper sind in österreich
den gasverbrauch zu drosseln aus diesem
dilemma herauszukommen
also ich würde sagen die situation ist
ziemlich ernst auch in österreich oder
vor allem in österreich denn dieses land
ist ja noch abhängiger von russischem
gas als deutschland 80 prozent des
gasverbrauchs kommen aus russland und
anders als in deutschland gab es bis
jetzt kaum anstrengungen diesen
prozentsatz auch zu drücken was ja in
deutschland doch schon geschehen ist
kommt mir von der österreichischen
perspektive erst einmal auf die
brüsseler perspektive helga schmidt
berichtet aus brüssel wie gut ist denn
die eu auf diese situation gerade
vorbereitet ist es realistisch dass
europäische regierung sich von der
kommission vorschreiben lassen so wie es
laut von der leyen sich das vorstellt
ihre reserven zu teilen ihren gaskonsum
um 15 prozent zu reduzieren
all das zu tun im sinne der gemeinschaft
ja ursula von der leyen hat ja als
kommissions- der film schon ziemlich
deutlich gemacht dass sie sich auch
vorstellen kann das als zwangs als
notmaßnahme durchzusetzen dass alle in
europa 15 prozent sparen beim gas und da
hat es interessante reaktionen gegeben
protest aus osteuropa das war zu
erwarten da gibt es viel kritik an
deutschland dass die bundesregierung
unter angela merkel im wesentlichen sich
so abhängig gemacht hat von
gaslieferungen aus russland aber jetzt
interessanterweise auch aus südeuropa
aus portugal aus spanien und da gab es
die stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin
in spanien die sagte na ja
solidarität das sieht sie eigentlich
nicht dass spanier das südeuropäer
sparen nachdem man ja vorher von anderen
ländern auch nicht allzu viel
solidarität erfahren hat und daran
merkte man so deutschland war noch nicht
ausgesprochen aber man merkte es könnte
jetzt schwierig werden denn deutschland
ist ja nicht nur
sehr abhängig vom gas ist auch die
größte volkswirtschaft das heißt wenn
die industrie in deutschland weniger
deutlich weniger produzieren kann dann
hat das zwei auswirkungen dann werden
lieferketten unterbrochen in ganz europa
und wichtig für die ärmeren eu länder
dann wird auch der größte nettozahler
ärmer dh es kann auch weniger in die
gemeinschafts zahlen kassen einzahlen
also das ist jetzt sehr offen wie dieser
sparappell ausgehen werden ich eröffne
die runde jetzt gerne mit der nächsten
frage am dienstag wird es in dieser
frage habe möglicherweise schon zum
schwur kommen dann werden sich die
eu-energieminister treffen und dann wird
man schauen ob sie sich tatsächlich auf
diesen gas notfallplan einigen können
sind sie tatsächlich bereit dazu herr
cornelius glauben sie durch sind die da
solidarisch ich glaube ich dass es so
weit kommen dass sich entscheiden können
weil es tatsächlich ein problem von
großer großer komplexität ist und das
meiner meinung nach erfordert hast die
regierungschefs sich damit beschäftigen
dass auch bessere vorbereitung bedarf
was sie geschildert haben ist ja genau
da der widerspruch die die südländer
spanien/portugal leben von allen stars
das wiederum bei ihnen verbleiben sollen
wir können schon technisch gar nicht so
viel nach westen nach mitteleuropa nach
deutschland davon schicken umgekehrt
gibt es die gegen abhängigkeit von der
deutschen kaufkraft der deutschen von
deutsche lieferketten die deutsche
chemieindustrie ist der hauptnutzen
dieser des russischen gases denn die
grundlagen der die verbundstoffe die
dort produziert werden ausbleiben dann
hat das folgen in alle teile europas
hinein also ich glaube diesen
solidaritäts mechanismus muss man noch
mal genauer anschauen
und jetzt nachdem die die nord stream 1
wieder zu 40 prozent gefüllt ist also
quasi auf dem vorfall level steht könnte
sich auch so eine art
er hat bräsigkeit anstellen eine art
zufriedenheit irgendwie wird schon
klappen ich glaube es nicht aber ich
glaube auch nicht dass entkommen die
entscheidungs dichte schon da bonn will
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass die
europäische solidarität spätestens im
winter auf der strecke bleibt wenn es
wirklich kalt wird und wenn echte härten
kommen
das problem ist natürlich dabei wir
haben keine alternative die eu muss
geschlossen reagieren und sie muss eine
antwort finden auf putins aggressionen
auf russlands aggression das hat
tragweite die nicht nur die ukraine
betrifft sondern die unser zusammenleben
auf dem europäischen kontinent betrifft
insgesamt und das nützt alles nichts wir
müssen da die europäer müssen da
irgendwie durch insofern wie die lösung
aussehen kann weiß ich auch nicht ich
glaube niemand weiß das bisher aber es
muss eine lösung gefunden werden und im
zweifelsfall muss man sich einfach
klarmachen dass so eine situation jetzt
und zwar nicht verschuldet durch die eu
sondern verschuldet durch russland durch
putin einfach auch abstriche in der
europäischen union erfordert im
lebensstandard
in dem wohlstand den wir gewohnt sind
und da ist natürlich umverteilung nötig
und soziale ausgleichsprogramme für all
jene die jetzt wirklich gucken müssen
wie viel geld sie noch in der tasche
haben wer ist hier besonders in der
pflicht die kolleginnen haben schon
darüber gesprochen deutschland ist
ausgesprochen abhängig von russischem
gas österreich ebenfalls sind es diese
länder von denen man jetzt auch erwarten
kann dass er sich verantwortlich fühlen
und für solidarität werben untereinander
ja das stichwort wir haben ich glaube
das ist jetzt die herausforderung für
die bundesregierung die die anderen
länder dafür zu gewinnen solidarisch
dieses mal auch mal mit deutschland zu
sein dass er noch nicht so oft
vorgekommen aber dann gibt es eben
einwände länder die sagen na gut
deutschland ist ausgestiegen aus der
atomenergie ohne die erneuerbaren
aufzubauen zehn jahre ist fast nichts
getan worden zum ausbau der erneuerbaren
in deutschland stellenweise
zurückgefahren das ist in spanien und
portugal anders gewesen dann gibt es
länder die sagen in deutschland hat das
risiko nicht genügend gestreut wenn ein
land 55 prozent vom gas auch von einem
diktator abhängig macht das war nicht
geschickt andere länder haben dann auch
gas aus nordafrika bezogen lng und auch
als algerien da sind die südeuropäer vor
allen dingen also das wird jetzt eine
schwierige aufgabe für die
bundesregierung die ja vorgelegt hat
tatsächlich schon eingespart hat aber
deren aufgabe es jetzt an sein wird in
den kommenden wochen dafür zu werben
dass es im interesse aller anderen 26
mitglieder auch liegt nun gemeinsam den
gasverbrauch zu drosseln damit die
großen volkswirtschaften weiter
produzieren können frau berger auf
welche
gerechtigkeitsfragen wie die eu
antworten finden müssen wenn wir jetzt
echte verteilungsdebatte bekommen naja
wie angesprochen sicher zwischen nord
und süd ja also ich
kann mir vorstellen dass das die länder
im süden europas spezielles italien
zuletzt sich noch gut daran erinnern wie
die sogenannten sozialen vier versucht
haben vor zwei jahren die befüllung des
wiederaufbaus zu drosseln keine keine
also kredite zuzulassen und keine
zuschüsse ich kann mich noch erinnern an
unserem bundeskanzler sebastian kurz der
damals auf europäischer ebene großes
wort geführt hat und von kaputten
systemen sprach in anderen ländern also
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der süden
jetzt durchaus
berechtigte forderungen stellt und
interessen hat und ihm die müssen wir
die müssen wir berücksichtigen also ich
denke auch da wird viel
überzeugungsarbeit notwendig seien am
ende bin ich aber dann doch optimistisch
dass das gelingt so einen notfallplan
auf die beine zu stellen denn
angesprochen war schon die größte
volkswirtschaft europas wenn dienst
rüben gerät dann erzeugt das einen zug
der andere auch mitnimmt und die andere
frage ist
genau das wäre putins erster großer
etappensieg in diesem krieg europa
wirklich zu spalten und uneins zu machen
und scheitern zu lassen naja die
europäische solidarität beginnt ja schon
zu bröckeln an diesem wochenende zum
beispiel bringt viktor orban nochmal
neuen spin in die debatte um sanktionen
er sagt es geht nicht mehr in erster
linie um unterstützung für die ukraine
es geht möglicherweise vielmehr um
friedensverhandlungen zwischen russen
und ukrainern sehen wir hier den anfang
vom ende der europäischen solidarität
also so weit würde ich auf keinen fall
gehen und die rede von orban muss man
sich ja auch ganz angucken also er sagt
ja auch
verhandlungen zwischen der ukraine und
russland design gar nicht möglich
sondern da müssten russland und die
amerikaner sich einigen und die ukraine
die müssen dann schon irgendwie
mitmachen also das ist das übliche
populistische und auch letztendlich
großmacht gerede und so weit darf es
natürlich überhaupt nicht kommen was
mich ein bisschen stört an der debatte
auch wie wir sie führen es wir reden
darüber berechtigterweise welche gefahr
besteht für die europäische union zu
zerbrechen und wir müssen dann natürlich
lösungen finden aber mir geht ein
bisschen aus dem blick verloren dabei
stellen wir uns doch mal vor wir drehen
die frage einfach um was können wir
machen wie groß ist das risiko dass
russland zerbricht an den sanktionen das
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass wird
vielleicht ist noch ein bisschen
wunschdenken von all den
intellektuellen und politischen gegnern
die ja in zahlreicher zahl inzwischen im
ausland sind aber mir fehlt bei all dem
berechtigten lamentieren über die frage
wie schlimm es in der europäischen union
ist eine debatte darüber wo sind die
schwachstellen in putins russland und
wie können wir das auch strategisch
nutzen
wunderbare stichwort ich öffne gerne das
nächste kapitel in unserer runde nachdem
wir jetzt erstmal auf die aktuelle lage
und das russische gas geschaut haben
lassen sie uns gerne sehr grundsätzlich
auf die sanktionen gegen russland
schauen und die frage stellen wem den
nutzen und wen sie schaden also auch
nach der besetzung der krim hat es ja
schon sanktionen gegeben damals waren
sie aber offenbar so schwach und so
wirkungslos das diesmal wenig passiert
ist was ist diesmal anders sind sie
wirklich entschlossen massiver
wirkungsvoller die sanktionen der
europäer sind deutlich massiver system
deutlich mächtiger das beginnt natürlich
mit dem zahlungssystem mit der
abschaltung der ab mit dem abkapseln los
land aus dem internationalen
währungsfonds flüssen es geht weiter mit
vor allem technologieaktien die russland
besonders hart treffen auch kurzfristig
treffen werden und dann natürlich auch
die entscheidung zum öl embargo ist eine
sanktion die durchaus ihre wirkung
entfalten wird die öleinnahmen
addieren sich zu 20 prozent des
russischen haushalt des während gasen
das mit meint ich vorhin hat keine
auswirkung sich nur zu drei prozent des
russischen budgets summieren nebenbei
ist es völlig irrelevant ob putin in
euro oder dollar oder wie auch immer
ausländische haben kann sich davon wenig
kaufen und die leute die er zahlen muss
oder die kaufkraft der im land bedienen
muss kann dadurch die notenpresse auch
bedienen also die russische
volkswirtschaft schrumpft immer mehr sie
hat keinen sie hat keinen technologie
zufluss mehr und der markt also man
sieht es auch am exportüberschuss in das
land momentan wirtschaftlich 15 prozent
im vergleich zum vorjahr ist eine enorme
zahl was bedeutet dass das gas fließt
raus das öl fließt auch noch zum teil
raus aber es kommt nichts mehr rein und
das kapital fließt ab das heißt russland
kommt in einer ganz große schieflage und
wann sich das dann zusammen mit einem
knall löst das wissen wir alle nicht
aber es wird sich lösen das geht nicht
in sechs monaten vielleicht auch nicht
in zwölf aber es wird passieren dass
eine erste antwort schon auf friedemann
zahl der bei uns im gästebuch fragt bei
der vielzahl an funktionen verliert man
den überblick welche werden als die
wirksamsten erachtet und welche sind
eher symbolischer natur
also die wirksamsten sind schon genannt
ich denke die wirksamsten es sind das
sind die verbote für lieferung von
maschinenteilen hochtechnologieprodukten
da hat sich die kommission übrigens
wochen schon vor kriegsbeginn
zusammengesetzt mit den amerikanern und
sie haben genau geguckt welche produkte
brauchen
die russischen unternehmen um zu
produzieren können sie sich nicht so
leicht auf dem chinesischen markt oder
an anderen stellen holen das sind einmal
computerteile computerchips vor allen
dingen lasertechnologie ganz wichtig
alles was man für den bau von
landmaschinen braucht etwas komplexer
hochtechnologie maschinenteile angeht
für den autobau auch und für den
flugzeugbau und da sind wir auch bei der
zweiten wirklich wirkenden maßnahmen der
flugverkehr ist ja im grunde
zusammengebrochen 70 prozent der
russischen flugzeuge sind airbus
maschinen oder boeing-maschinen die
werden nicht mehr gewartet da gibt es
keine ersatzteillieferungen mehr das
bedeutet die kommission in brüssel geht
davon aus dass über kurz oder lang
dieses land gar nicht mehr im
internationalen flugverkehr teilnehmen
kann in europa und an den anderen
ländern können maschinen ohnehin nicht
mehr landen und das ist natürlich dann
schon eine einschränkung im
geschäftsverkehr im wirtschaft in der ge
wirtschaftskommunikation auch und ein
dritter wird betrifft auch
hochtechnologie produkte die auch in der
rüstungs technologie gebraucht werden
die russland nicht alleine herstellen
kann da gibt es so die ersten hinweise
aus dem amerikanischen
verteidigungsministerium wo man offenbar
festgestellt hat dass
waffen komplexere waffen
raketensysteme hochkomplexe
raketensysteme die zu beginn des krieges
noch eingesetzt wurden dass man die
jetzt seltener und zum teil gar nicht
mehr sieht und das führe neben militär
experten in washington darauf zurück
dass sich ein mangel bei bemerkbar
machen inzwischen das kann ich ja das
kann nicht gern bestätigen und würde ich
gern fortführen wenn man fragt danach
was besonders effektvoll ist so muss man
sich natürlich überlegen im hinblick auf
welches ziel und ich denke das
wichtigste ziel so zeit muss sein
russland nicht weiter zu befähigen
diesen krieg zu führen und insofern sind
alle sanktionen die auf die
rüstungsindustrie zielen natürlich
besonders wichtig und es ist sehr
positiv dass es da anzeichen gibt dass
die tatsächlich wirken einmal das was
sie gesagt haben es gibt auch die
meldung dass russland seine
rüstungsexport verträge mit
afrikanischen ländern nicht weiter
einhalten kann dass es da massive
probleme gibt
insgesamt ist es aber so dass die
russische wirtschaft betroffen ist dass
sie schrumpft sie schrumpft aber nicht
so schnell wie dass mancher sich erhofft
hatte aber es gibt jetzt zum beispiel
prognosen einmal das
bruttoinlandsprodukt hat seit februar
bis jetzt ist zurückgegangen um ungefähr
6% oder sogar etwas mehr die prognosen
bis zum jahresende belaufen sich auf
minus 10 bis minus sogar 15 prozent wenn
wir die autoindustrie nehmen da gibt es
eine wirkliche überraschung der zahl die
ist vom mai letzten jahres auf jetzt mai
diesen jahres um 97 prozent gesunken nun
ist diese sparte besonders abhängig von
zulieferteilen aber auch all die anderen
wo sie richtig gesagt haben chips und so
weiter mikrochips gibt es nicht da hatte
russland gehofft china würde einspringen
aber china ist eben auch in vielen
bereichen aus russlands rausgegangen
wirtschaftlich weil sie eben keine
sanktionen riskieren wollen von
amerikanischer seite sie haben gesagt es
kommt auch sehr darauf an zu sagen was
eigentlich das ziel der sanktionen worum
geht es ja eigentlich predator worum
geht's geht es darum putin in die knie
zu zwingen ihm finanziell zu schaden
dass er den krieg nicht weiterführen
kann geht es darum die russische
bevölkerung spüren zu lassen welche
folgen diese militärische
spezialoperation so wird es ja in
russland genannt das darf nicht krieg
genannt werden hat geht es darum oder
geht es vor allen dingen um ein zeichen
der unterstützung für die ukraine was
ist der wichtigste sind das ziel der
sanktionen für mich geht es darum
putin so weit zu bringen dass er diesen
krieg nicht mehr so fortsetzen kann wie
er es geplant hat dass er verhandlungen
führen muss irgendwann ohne abreißen zu
können
denn man sieht ja was was abkommen über
die getreide lieferungen die sie
apotheken als verhandlungspartner
verlässlich ist nämlich gar nicht also
solange nicht gezwungen ist zu
verhandeln wir da wir das sich an keine
zusagen halten das ist das ziel der
sanktionen
dass er diesen krieg stoppen muss
verhandeln muss und man muss ja diese
sanktionen sehen im paket mit den
militärischen
hilfen für die ukraine aus meiner sicht
beides wirkt zusammen 1 allein wirkt
nicht und für mich ist der punkt dass es
keine alternative gibt zu strengen
sanktionen zu starken massiven
sanktionen wie eine alternative wäre
zuzusehen wie putin die ukraine dem
erdboden gleich gemacht dass es keine
die andere wäre in den krieg einzutreten
für den westen ist auch keine also es
gibt keine alternative zu diesen
sanktionen
allein darf ich gab es ja was ergänzen
stimme völlig zu putin muss verhandeln
aber es müssen echte verhandlungen und
die wird putin nur aus einer position
der schwäche führen also beziehungsweise
wenn er nicht mehr überzeugt davon ist
dass russland am längeren hebel sitzt
nicht gehen aber das wissen wir also es
selbst sein verhalten der letzten monate
und jahre hatte eben auch eigentlich
gezeigt dass ja auch gar nicht
wahrnehmen ob er in eine position der
schwäche gerät und nun hat die russische
regierung selbst angekündigt dass die
gesamte volkswirtschaft umgestellt wird
auf eine kriegswirtschaft das heißt die
bevölkerung wird eingeschworen auf auf
herten die produktion wird umgestellt
man kann auch schon erwarten dass
fachkräfte aus der aus der
energieproduktion ihnen die
rüstungsproduktion verlagert werden also
ich warne davor jetzt auch schnelle
wirkung der sanktionen zu erwarten das
kann sich fand anklang hinzu das wird in
einigen bereichen hat russland die
folgen der sanktionen der
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen ja besser
weggesteckt als erwartet der rubel ist
ein gutes beispiel der ist stärker als
erwartet er ist in der letzten zeit
sogar noch stärker geworden ist das ein
beispiel dafür wo sich die europäer
vielleicht auch dramatisch verschätzt
haben ich glaube nicht dass sie sich
verschätzt haben was was was kann man
mit dem rubel kaufen außer waffen und
das müssen dann auch noch russische sein
das ist eine momentaufnahme in der
kommission und auch im rat der
mitgliedsländer hat sich glaube ich
niemand die illusion gemacht dass man
putin nun kurzfristig oder auch nur
mittelfristig in die knie zwingen kann
durch diese sanktionen
und es ist sogar die frage
ob die bevölkerung das in irgendeiner
weise sanktioniert seine macht gründet
ja nicht auf wirtschaftlichem wohlstand
breiter schichten oder auf einem
funktionierenden wirtschaftssystem im
gegenteil seine macht gründet auf dem
militär so dass ich mir vorstellen kann
das wirklich der einfluss der sanktionen
auf die auf die einsatzfähigkeit des
militärs auf die rüstungsindustrie das
könnte etwas bewirken und
möglicherweise das ist eine hoffnung
oder spricht man auch ganz offen so aus
unter den diplomaten die hoffnung dass
diese erfahrung dass putin das land doch
in einen freien fall geführt hat
international diskreditiert ja ich weiss
nur im westen in anderen teilen der erde
nicht das muss man berücksichtigen
trotzdem dieser image verlust und diese
aussicht kein ausweg zu haben dass das
möglicherweise doch die noch vorhandene
opposition in russland motivieren könnte
zu sehen ja dem westen lässt uns nicht
alleine aber das ist eine hoffnung dass
man wohnt und doch gibt es ja auch
zweifel an der europäischen sagen zu uns
politik also in unserem gästebuch zum
beispiel fragt hans es wie kann die
eskalationsspirale unterbrochen worden
wem haben die sanktionen gegen russland
mehr geschadet und auch josef bugl der
eu außenbeauftragte der stellt
inzwischen öffentlich die frage ob die
eu sich mit sanktionen nicht selbst mehr
schade als russland einige starts selbst
seien bereits der meinung sanktionen sei
ein fehler gewesen
wie groß und wie verbreitet ist diese
stimmung diese meinung in der
europäischen union
ich sehe da eine eine große gefahr weil
natürlich die nationalen regierungen
angesichts der preissteigerungen der
inflation unter druck kommen stehen da
dort waren wahlen bevor also was europa
jetzt braucht ist ein langer atem ist
sie haben das schon gepackt eine art
opferbereitschaft die frage ist immer
wie kann man denen die am meisten
betroffen sind diese opfer abgelten aber
die opfer finde ich sind berechtigt um
putin zu stoppen denn er bedroht bedroht
die europäische union direkt er hat ja
klar gesagt was er will ja klar gesagt
er will einflusszone in osteuropa er hat
klar gesagt er will zurück zu einem
status quo der
sowjetunion mehr oder weniger also wenn
das nicht ein grund ist opfer zu bringen
auch wenn man die schwächsten schützen
muss dann weiß ich nicht was ein grund
denn völlig recht dass es erstaunlich
wie wenig ernst hierzulande diese
bedrohung inzwischen diskutiert wird der
economist hat es am freitag geschrieben
auch andere gruppe sehr stark auf
deutschland sagen wann wacht dieses land
endlich auf und versteht dass es mitten
drin in diesem krieg stecken nicht
natürlich militärisch aber wir sind das
hauptziel als das land das die
europäische union zusammen hält auch
ökonomisch auch politisch muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen den ausgleich
zwischen süd und nord und nur immer
schafft jetzt ist beim gas die die
deutschen gasimporte aus russland gehen
ja wieder zu 20 bis 30 prozent je nach
wetterlage oder was auch immer aus dem
land hinaus als transitgas quasi die
größte reich die gegen die slowakei die
gehen nach ungarn dass die länder die
haben wirklich angst davor dass wie
deutschland in die knie geht und
ich vermisse auch als der kanzler jetzt
am freitag aus dem urlaub zurückkam und
seine ja es war keine blut schweiß
tränen rede es war einfach ja
und du bist du wirst nicht alleine
gelassen aber das ist wie soll ich sagen
die ehrliche ansage wäre gewesen es wird
uns nach dieser krise nicht mehr so gut
gehen wie wurde krise
gerade beschrieben wird woher kommt
dieser unernst in der diskussion wenn
sie das teilen ist es nicht auch ein
bisschen an eliten problem oder ein
problem des öffentlichen diskurses es
gab doch diese umfrage vor einiger zeit
wie viele menschen in deutschland bereit
sein die ukraine zu unterstützen auch
wenn es einschnitte gibt ich weiß nicht
mehr genau wie die frage formuliert war
vielleicht erinnern sie sich und es war
eigentlich auch innerhalb der spd bei
den grünen wählern waren es am meisten
bei afg natürlich ganz wenig aber es war
auch bei den bei den anderen parteien
eine eine stimmung und eine bereitschaft
opfer zu bringen die sich in der politik
der des bundeskanzlers so würde es für
mich so nicht widerspiegelt und ich
frage mich ob man nicht auch wenn ich
mich umhöre nun habe ich natürlich lebe
ich auch in meiner blase aber ich habe
das gefühl auch wenn ich mit leuten rede
die die jetzt nicht journalisten sind
das doch irgendwie ist unheimlich viele
menschen mit normalem menschenverstand
gibt die auch sagen ja wir müssen jetzt
mal irgendwie uns am riemen reißen ich
glaube es ist nicht die zeit mehr für
blut schweiß und tränen rede ich denke
der bundeskanzler hat geantwortet auf
die sorgen in der bevölkerung die viele
menschen haben ja
und ich finde man muss fairerweise aber
auch noch mal anschauen was eigentlich
in den vergangen sechs sieben acht
monaten geschehen ist was die neue
bundesregierung sie ist ja immer noch
ein bisschen neu gemacht hat in dieser
zeit eine komplette kehrtwende im
vergleich zu jahrzehntealter
rüstungspolitik es werden waffen in ein
kriegsgebiet geliefert und denkbar bis
zum 24 februar dieses jahres sie hat
entschieden aus dem öl auszusteigen im
mai war das im mai dieses jahres völlig
unvorstellbar da hat die eu beschlossen
die sanktionen ein embargo zu fallen
kein öl mehr zu kaufen in russland das
ist ende dieses jahres wird das
umgesetzt das hat er eigentlich kaum
jemand auf dem schirm dass deutschland
das so schnell schaffen würde und in
ostdeutschland gibt es ja immer noch
große sorgen in schwedt und an anderen
stellen ob das überhaupt umgesetzt
werden kann weil man da abhängig ist von
den öllieferungen aus der durch die
pipeline also da hat man auch eine
lösung gefunden mit mit
übergangslösungen mit ausnahmen für
ungarn in dem fall und einige andere
mitteleuropäische mittel osteuropäische
länder aber das zeigt ja dass ich enorm
viel bewegt hat in dieser zeit und
gleichzeitig hat die bundesregierung ja
auch noch die wie ich finde
jahrhundertaufgabe die klimakrise zu
bekämpfen das müssen sie jetzt auch noch
umsetzen da gibt es einige die sagen gut
man kann auch diesen krieg und diese
situation zum anlass nehmen das zu
beschleunigen
aber das alles unter einen hut zu
bringen in einem wirtschaftsministerium
mit einem wirtschaftsministerium das ja
über zehn jahre eine ganz andere politik
gemacht hat gegen die erneuerbaren sich
engagiert hat bis in abteilungsleiter
ebene also ich finde das jetzt aus der
ferne aus brüssel betrachtet wo ich
normalerweise arbeite er beeindruckend
was da an wandel an änderungen an change
bisher geschafft worden ist ich bin mal
ein bisschen die spielverderberin teil
jetzt mal nicht ihren optimismus und
ihre zuversicht an dieser stelle möchte
mal fragen was ist aber wenn sich die
energiekrise tatsächlich weiter
verschärft wenn die inflation
fortschreitet wenn es eine
teuerungswelle gibt die sich in den
nächsten monaten tatsächlich bis in die
mittelschicht rein frisst wie groß ist
die gefahr dass dann tatsächlich die
stimmung umschlägt da in der bevölkerung
dass immer mehr menschen sagen wir
müssen jetzt auch hier nach schauen und
wir wollen vor einigen frieden in der
ukraine aber was heißt das was heißt es
dann wir schauen nach uns heißt das dass
man sagen jetzt ist die ignorieren den
krieg das ist ja dass das argument des
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten der sagt
lasst uns das einfrieren und verhandeln
ich sehe nicht dass da jemand verhandeln
möchte und ich sehe auch nicht dass es
sehr klug ist das an der position der
schwäche oder der bittsteller rey zu
verhandeln
dass es wird den krieg nicht beenden wir
müssen doch dort anfangen wo der krieg
tatsächlich nämlich man kriegsziel also
was möchte putin sie haben ja gesagt was
er weiß was seine ultimativen ziele sind
immer irgendwo ins utopische ein oder
oder enorm weit gefasst aber das ist das
was er sagt muss man ihnen bei diesen
worten nehmen das nächste ist können
kann man sich darauf verlassen dass eine
verhandlungslösung auch tatsächlich zu
einer lösung führt nein wir können ist
weder von der russischen seite wie wir
jetzt besser gesehen haben wo der hafen
einen tag nach der nach dem weizen
abkommen bombardiert wurde und wir
können uns ist nebenbei auch nicht auf
die ukrainische seite verlassen weil
dort auch keine bereitschaft besteht ein
frieden zu schließen so lange die
hoffnung besteht teile des eroberten
gebiete zurückzuerobern also ich glaube
deutschland überschätzt sich daher
glauben wir können da irgendwas separate
nummern und dann wild wie sehen sie
diese debatte um das einfrieren des
konflikts wie gefährlich es geht dies
sehr gefährlich das da muss man sich nur
erinnern was nach 2014 2015 passiert ist
und der donbass das ist ja nicht nur der
erste gar nicht wirklich eingefrorenen
konflikt das war ja nie nach dem minsker
abkommen 2015 das hat ja dann immer
weiter opfer gegeben aber wir haben ja
vorher in transnistrien in georgien
abchasien und südossetien 20 prozent der
georgischen gebiete sind russisch
besetzt wir haben gesehen dass das
keinen dauerhaften frieden bringt und
die befürchtung ist einfach dass
russland das putin eine pause nun nutzen
würde um weiter aufzurüsten sich zu
erholen die russische rüstungsindustrie
wieder auf die beine zu stellen weiter
auf die beine zu stellen die armee neu
zu sortieren und dann weiterzumachen und
dann muss man auch noch sind das ist
eigentlich die ukraine sind die zu
entscheiden haben ob und wann verhandelt
wird das also diese debatte finde ich
ein bisschen zynisch die zum teil
geführt wird hier
und noch mal zur zur rolle rolle
brüssels ich schließe mich an ich fand
es auch beeindruckend was in der kurzen
zeit in fünf monaten alles geschehen ist
wenn man sich vorstellt dass 27
zusammenfinden müssen ja wenn wenn man
sich überlegt wie in unseren staaten
bund und länder zusammen wirken und wie
lange da vergleichsweise kleine
reformprozesse dauern dann fand ich die
antwort die jetzt in fünf monaten durch
die europäische union gegeben wurde
durchaus beeindruckend deshalb bin ich
auch nicht so bank hat dieser
notfallplan wenn auch nicht am dienstag
eventuell dann doch kommen wird und man
muss auch noch eines sagen nämlich zu
ordern nach zuvor hin
auch er hat bis jetzt allen sanktions
paketen zugestimmt und er ist zu hause
in ungarn im moment schwer unter druck
und ich würde meinen diese diese starken
worte diese starke rhetorik gegen
brüssel dies auch der eigenen galerie
geschuldet bleiben wir noch mal bei
diesem stichwort vom eingefrorenen
konflikt was es tatsächlich wenn putin
nach der einnahme des donners halt macht
wenn er einen friedens werden
verhandlungsangebot machen sollte wie
groß wäre dann die versuchung der
europäer sich auf -3 tatsächlich
einzulassen
nach allem was wir von diplomaten hören
gibt es da im moment keine bereitschaft
das in diesem kleinen zirkel verhandeln
zu lassen da waren ja deutschland und
frankreich sozusagen federführer bei der
vermittlung zwischen russland und
ukrainischen vertretern also diese
vierergruppe
da gibt es im moment weniger anzeichen
die erneut aufzulegen
aber der zweite satz ist immer das muss
die ukraine entscheiden wie dann
verhandelt wird in welchem format
verhandelt wird dann muss das muss der
ukrainische präsident mit seiner
regierung entscheiden da gibt es im
moment
große zurückhaltung in brüssel in der
kommission aber auch bei allen
mitgliedsländern
ist ein szenario denkbar in dem rechte
parteien populisten propagandisten
versuchen zweifel an sanktionen für ihre
zwecke zu nutzen in italien zum beispiel
mit orange ist das beste beispiel jetzt
wir wissen nicht wie die wahl ausgehen
wird ich habe dass wir am ende etwas
übertrieben dass er jetzt sofort einer
postfaschistischen dort als
ministerpräsidentin sehen der wahlkampf
hat erstmal beginnen und jetzt nur viel
passieren aber
natürlich kann das überall passieren der
kern ist ja die die homogen europäischen
union also lässt sich dieser verein
zusammen halten gibt es ausgleich mehr
seien mechanismen versteht diese eu dass
das eigentliche ziel putin sie auch
mehrfach deklariert da die spaltung der
eu ist nur eine gespaltene ist eine
schwache eu wenn putin mit jedem
europäischen staates separat verhandeln
kann es ist ein traum das ist auch das
was er sich wünscht das ist die rückkehr
russlands zu der größe die er meint
wieder herstellen zu müssen ich gönne
russland alle größe aber eben zu
konditionen dazu regeln die wir
möglichst beide unter gleich
unterschreiben und insofern benutzt er
auch rechtspopulisten und extremisten um
diese um diesen nationalismus in europa
zu fördern in frankreich le pen
auch in deutschland natürlich die afd
und das ist in österreich der fall und
vp entschuldigung
spielt auf dem klavier sehr sehr kräftig
sein und dann kommt auch noch dazu dass
möglicherweise aber nicht möglicherweise
sondern davon gehe ich eigentlich aus
dass auch crooner maßnahmen gegner in
dieses boot steigen werden also ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass wir im herbst
durchaus neue proteste aus diesem aus
diesem bereich populisten corona
maßnahmen gegner
erleben werden also ein geschwächter
binnenmarkt dritten mitgliedstaaten
möglicherweise perspektivisch proteste
auf der strasse erstarken rechter kräfte
das klingt schon nach einer zerreißprobe
für europa oder verdorben wird ja das
ist das was platini putin wahrscheinlich
mit großer freude und befriedigung
beobachtet und sich auch mit auf die
fahnen schreiben kann zum teil den
russland hat ja diese zwiespälte
ordentlich gefördert aber es nützt alles
nichts wir müssen der realität ins auge
sehen also ein waffenstillstand den wie
gesagt nur die ukraine überhaupt die
verhandlungen darüber in gang bringen
kann so einschlafen waffenstillstand
würde das problem nicht lösen wir müssen
uns noch mal vor augen führen was für
ein start was für eine gesellschaft auch
in russland wir haben zurzeit das
beschäftigt mich sehr das nachdenken
darüber denn das ist nicht nur putin an
der spitze der revanchistisch und
chauvinistisch ist sondern es ist eine
ganze generation die von putin geprägt
ist ich habe immer noch in den ohren und
auch vor augen wie putin 2012 als er
gewählt wurde zurück ins präsidentenamt
präsidentenamt sagte wir sind ein sieger
volk wir haben das in unseren genen und
das hört man immer wieder und das ist
dauerhaft weit über den ukraine den
krieg gegen die ukraine hinaus der
hoffentlich bald beendet sein möge ein
problem für die eu
hat die eu das schon in letzter
konsequenz verstanden es sie wirklich
angekommen in der neuen geopolitischen
realität und sie gerüstet dem zu
widerstehen wenn wir das jetzt die
kommissionschefin fragen würde würden
käme ein klares ja und ich finde sie hat
auch einiges erreicht von ihren zielen
die sie vorgegeben hat also ich meine
wer hätte das gedacht dass sie die
korona krise so gut managt also zwei
deutsche ministerpräsident ist es fast
vergessen einer aus bayern einer aus
sachsen haben ja bei putin um impfstoff
gebeten und denen auch bestellt weil sie
brüssel nicht zugetraut habe und die
lupe sollte nicht nachher keiner habe ja
weil sie brüssel nicht zutrauten und
insbesondere vor von alleine nicht
zutrauten die impfstoffe zu organisieren
dass das darf man nicht vergessen das
war schon die erste große
herausforderung und das hat die
kommission wie ich finde sehr
professionell gemacht die kommission
sind nun in einer schärfe massivität und
intensiviert intensität mit amerika auch
abgesprochen wie wir das vorher nie
gesehen haben da haben die auch
führungsanspruch erkennen lassen es gibt
sogar schon einige in brüssel die
überlegen ob die kommission jetzt nicht
so mächtig wird aber ich glaube in der
jetzigen situation
ist es ist es genau die richtige
entwicklung es muss zentral gesteuert
werden und wenn es gelingt dass die
quertreiber auf viktor orban beschränkt
bleiben also das hat ja niemanden
überrascht dass viktor orban immer
wieder sonderkonditionen aushandelte so
ist er eben und so ist er motiviert
worden in den vergangenen jahren nun
muss er zum ersten mal auch geld
einbußen fürchten also vielleicht hilft
aber wenn es gelingt das auf ihn zu
beschränken und ansonsten die
geschlossenheit die ja nun fünf monate
auch überraschend gut gehalten hat dann
sehe ich die zukunft nicht so düster
dann müssten natürlich deutschland und
frankreich bereit sein die kommission
spitze zu unterstützen in diesem handeln
herr cornelius steilen sie so viel
optimismus mit blick auf die stärke und
die solidarität europas nicht ganz ich
erinnere nur an die kaliningrad episode
als wir vor einigen tagen und wochen
diese blockade des kaliningrad korridors
zwischen realos und der ex klar wird
diskutiert haben und es dort massive
meinungsunterschiede innerhalb der
kommission gehabt wie damit umzugehen
ist auch von von falken in der
kommission der baltischen fraktion
weiter gefördert haben jetzt eine
instant eingehen müssen aber nicht aber
es gibt diesen konsens nicht zwingend
ich teile auch das viel erreicht wurde
aber wenn wir drei dinge für wichtig
erachten nämlich resilienz als er sich
selbst stark zu machen unabhängigkeit
zweitens waffenlieferungen und drittens
auch die politische einigkeit zu wahren
es ist überall ein bisschen was
geschehen aber nicht ausreichen das kann
lange
wir kommen schon auf die schülers gerade
deswegen wo sich jetzt tatsächlich zum
ende kommen wir sind tatsächlich am ende
der sendung angelangt ich danke der
runde für diese engagierte diskussion
hier geht's jetzt weiter mit der europa
avantgarde 10 dokumentation zum thema
europas meere in gefahr und dem
presseclub nachgefragt den gibt es jetzt
wie immer auch phoenix und im radio auf
wdr 5 danke für ihr interesse ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]
so und ich begrüße sie herzlich zum
pressegespräch
und im radio auf wdr5 sanktionen gegen
russland zerreißprobe für europa das ist
das thema unserer runde heute im
presseclub und jetzt sind sie dran mit
ihren fragen an meine gäste sohn ich
schau mal
da haben wir zum beispiel uwe neuhaus
aus dinslaken herr neuhaus ich grüße sie
herzlich was ist ihre frage bitte
willi orban weiter gegen geld aus
russland bekommen
absoluter fronten
frau schmidt hübschen anja also viele
länder bekommen im moment ja noch gas
aus russland weil es dieses gas embargo
nicht gibt also orban hat jetzt wieder
alle überrascht mit der idee dass er
zusätzliches gas ball putin bestellen
will
ungarn ist schon sehr stark schon jetzt
sehr stark abhängig von von den
gaslieferungen aus russland
und ja das hat für ärger gesorgt in
brüssel aber durchaus nicht für große
überraschung weil es eigentlich immer so
ist dass der ungarische regierungschef
gerade wenn der innenpolitisch unter
druck steht versucht auf europäischer
ebene alleingänge zu realisieren mit
denen er dann zu hause
möglicherweise sein image aufpolieren
kann viktor orban stürmte war scheinen
noch mehr unserer zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer schon zu beschäftigen
alexander schwarz aus berlin zum
beispiel hat offenbar auch eine frage zu
viktor orban herr schwarz sie sind dran
bitter
dagegen die runde
ich wollte fragen aber für mich auch
eine große gefahr aus der sicht dass er
für die rechtspopulisten seine argumente
liefern weil die dann sagen werden
schaut mal zu wenn man nett zu putin ist
bekommt man das sogar zu
sonderkonditionen und wir haben hier den
ganzen winter über gefrorene
und deshalb trage ich wäre es nicht an
der zeit dass man jetzt den rechtsstaats
mechanismus aktiviert weil ich vermute
dass die polen diesmal nicht orban die
stange halten
diese tage würde gehen an frau gewinnen
frau darum geht sehr gerne nun bin ich
keine expertin für die rechtsstaats
mechanismen aber
natürlich muss was unternommen werden
und zwar dringend denn es ist genau
dieses spiel was putin nutzt die
einzelnen
eu-partner gegeneinander auszuspielen
und das ist fatal weil es eigenen weil
es einfach auch der eigenen propaganda
und seine machterhalt dient damit
letztlich wenn er zeigen kann dass er
rein grätschen kann in die eu die
nächste frage kommt von roland barwinsky
aus hirschberg saale herbei winski ich
grüße sie an diesem sonntag ihre frage
wie
auch und mich beunruhigt vor allen
dingen der brand erwidern also nehmen
wir mal an es kommt noch den 25
september zu einer rechtsregierung mit
solchen schillernden figuren soll wenige
und berlusconi denn dann vielleicht
diese aktionen egal sind und die dann
einfach sagen wir machen da nicht mal
mit wenn uns gut ihnen billiges gas gibt
vornehmlich gut weil die verfüllung jahr
gelogen sind unserem land und weil die
bevölkerung das vielleicht weil ich
näher will welche an bord hätte brüssel
die eu wie soll das funktionieren
beispielsweise aus scherz vielen dank
für die frage herr benz teams von dem
hätten sie gerne eine antwort
ja
stimmt wir teilen wir teilen eine grenze
also ich finde man sollte sich nicht
immer
vorbeugend fürchten vor dingen die
eintreten könnten ich denke daran dass
roger meloni wenn ich mich jetzt
wichtigere erst unlängst gesagt hat dass
die parteichefin der vaart l italia also
da in umfragen jetzt stärksten partei
dass sie zum beispiel auf jeden fall an
den waffenlieferungen an die ukraine
festhalten wollte das hier ist für mich
jetzt schon mal ein signal dass auch
diese diese diese gruppe nicht
ausscheren leute aus den sanktionen
zum anderen frage ich mich ob man so
einfach aus als ein land aus aktionen
ausführen kann die man gemeinsam
beschlossen hat ja
ich kann ihre frage nicht nicht mit
letzter gültigkeit beantworten aber ich
würde mal denken
dass man über diese brücke geht wenn sie
da ist und ich sehe die gefahr noch
nicht so riesig okay finde erst mal für
diese antworten dann machen wir gleich
weiter mit saskia winkenbach aus billig
frau winkenbach wo es billig
hallo also so jetzt können sie auch
sprechen hier in der runde es war mein
fehler hallo frau winken war ich grüße
sie conwert aus genau rufen sie uns an
[Musik]
wie
eine antwort auf die weitere zukünftige
bezugsmöglichkeit auch zwei weil
russland
sich ja insofern definitiv ein dass es
auch gut die länder die jetzt direkt
beliefert die zwischenhändler werden
auszuschalten und eben auch
dann weil
wir langfristig unseren bedarf
vielen dank für die frage ich versuche
sie an herrn cornelius weiterzuleiten in
weizen experten ja ich glaube dass das
eine einweg noch lange nicht wirklich in
der in der breite ausgereizt ist nämlich
die
die lieferung über die bahnverbindungen
nach nach mittel und westeuropa von der
ukraine das gibt juristische probleme es
gibt technische probleme in der umlage
die kapazitäten sind die stark genug da
aber das lässt sich ausbauen und da hat
die europäische union auch eine
verpflichtung dass sie diesen export weg
noch stärkt weil wir eigentlich damit
rechnen müssen dass der große export
nämlich über das schwarze meer über den
hafen oder besser trotz aller abkommen
nicht so schnell funktionieren wird wenn
er überhaupt jemals funktioniert wird
und ich glaube das ist die hoffnung dass
man den bahnen export auch der in den
straßentransport über die nachbarstaaten
über polen und diese staaten sind der
ukraine ausweitet vielen dank für diese
antwort danke für ihre frage nach billig
der nächste anruf oder die nächste
anruferin ist die st hat christmann aus
berlin nicht grüße in die hauptstadt was
ist ihre frage bitte
[Musik]
länder und eu eigentlich dass man dafür
bürger abgeholt und für all diese
sanktionen wie sie so geschlossen haben
um für die man sie so feiert die tollen
erfolge der eu und auch in den einzelnen
ländern ist erinnern nur an habe gesagt
wird dass die die hose geht dann haben
wir mit zitronen gehandelt wenn sie uns
mehr schadet als russland ich würde ganz
gerne wie sie denn das ansehen wie die
bevölkerung also sprich das mandat der
bevölkerung der jeweiligen regierung
abgeholt wurde damit man auch das
einfach ständig dafür hat frage herr
cornelius wenn möglich sonst könnten
sich auch die europäischen korrespondent
in europa großen momenten aus brüssel
antworten aber gerne herkommen ja dazu
sagen dass man da wir durch waren
erteilt und die wahl ist erfolgt und in
deutschland ist eine ampel regierung an
der regierung die diese entscheidung für
sie getroffen hat wenn sie damit nicht
einverstanden sind müssen sie zunächst
einmal nicht mehr wählen aber selbst
wenn sie nicht damit einverstanden sind
die frage ist doch wie misst man den
erfolg von sanktionen oder denn
umgekehrt die frage was für ein erfolg
würde sich dann einstellen wenn man
keines aktionär lesen und zu beiden
fragen kann ich ihnen keine
befriedigende antwort geben wir haben
viel diskutiert dass die sanktionen
nicht schnell wirken werden aber die
zweite frage nämlich was eigentlich
würde erzielt wenn wir wussten nicht
sanktionieren kann ich ihnen schnell
beantworten der krieg würde trotzdem
weitergehen der krieg hat deswegen nicht
auf russland belohnt kein wohlverhalten
und das ist glaube ich eine fehlannahme
die hier in diesem land auch sehr weit
verbreitet ist wie mit dem englischen
wort appeasement umschrieben ist und das
wird nicht funktionieren
margarete keller aus bremen ist die
nächste anruferin ich begrüße sie
herzlich und bitte sie um ihre frage
hallo frau kenner
[Musik]
wie solidarisch sind eigentlich die
energieunternehmen also
das was ich meine da hätte ich gerne
wirklich eine gute oder
kenntnisreiche antworten ich glaube
nicht und ich finde deren solidarität
ist auch gefragt also dass sie haben
zweifel an der solidarität der
energieunternehmen ja auf jeden fall
okay neben mir ja die erste aufgabe von
unternehmen ist ja nicht solidarität zu
erzeugen sondern die müssen gewinne
erwirtschaftet und auch in kriegszeiten
das ist so bitter das klingt einfach
wichtig für sie
und wenn sie auf juniper an spielen was
ich mir vorstellen kann da stellt sich
natürlich die frage frauen der bundes um
der deutsche staat da jetzt auch
finanziell sich so engagiert ja weil man
abhängig ist vom funktionieren dieses
unternehmens und das betrifft dann auch
die energieversorgung in deutschland
aber dass wirtschaftsunternehmen
solidarität üben ja da gibt es so
charity abteilungen aber die kalkulieren
nackt und nüchtern und schauen welche
gewinne sie machen können also ich
glaube da müsste man eher auf
politischer seite fragen welche
regelungen nötig sind um die gewinne im
zaum zu halten
da ist ja die über gewinn steuer im
moment auch diskutiert aber dass die
unternehmen das freiwillig tun
verzichten das glaube ich schon werden
anschließend von den
regierungen erwarte ich dass sie tätig
werden und dass sie den rahmen dafür
schaffen dass diese unternehmen die
jetzt über gebühr kriegs gewinn machen
davon einen teil zurückgeben an die
gesellschaft die die diese bitter nötig
hätte neben sozialen ausgleich zu üben
also eine eine wind volltexte über
gewinn steuer würde ich also für doch
angebracht halten vielen dank für die
antwort auf diese frage ich begrüße
jetzt henning magirus aus groß gerau
und bitte sie herr magirus gerne um ihre
frage
schönen guten tag und schön sonntag auf
dem ehemaligen freibad in groß gerau
form einer frage eine kurze anmerkung
ich bin seit jahren aufmerksamer
zuschauer des presseclubs ich muss sagen
in den letzten wochen hat sich doch
massiv diese sendung in eine fremde
veranstaltung verwandelt also sprich auf
deutsch die kunst des weglassens und
deswegen meine frage
die bild zeitung hat eine insel um frage
veröffentlicht diese woche
wonach 44 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung bereit ist auf die straße zu
gehen zu demonstrieren im herbst bei
steigenden gaspreisen ich bitte um
stellungnahme
das ist jetzt eigentlich erstmal eine
meinungsäußerung
wer möchte darauf reagieren sehen wir da
tatsächlich dass die die stimmung in der
bevölkerung kippen könnte vielleicht
habe ich nachfragen was was meinen sie
unter fremming also also es ist hier
leider nicht mehr da aber
vielleicht die frage ob die stimmung
kippt oder ob wir das hier falsch
einschätzen ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
nicht und auch noch mal die wiederholung
vielleicht aus und was ich vorhin in
anderen worten sagte was bitte würde ein
protest gegen steigende gaspreise nutzen
dass der gaspreis steigt weil das gas
verknappt wird unser gaspreis steigt
nicht weil herr putin gas liefert also
sollte man vielleicht in moskau
demonstrieren dass er mehr gas liefert
wir müssen das leider sehr nüchtern
sehen die sanktions gebilde ist ja ein
stück weit auch widersprüchlich
einerseits möchten wir dass russland vom
weltmarkt abgeschnitten wird auch von
den finanzmärkten auch von technologie
märkten andererseits sind wir auf das
gas angewiesen weil es uns mehr schadet
wenn wir es nicht bekommen und da muss
man ganz klar sagen
jedes land hat auch das interesse das zu
tun was ihm am ehesten nutzt und
natürlich nutzt es deutschland am
stärksten in der gasfluss weiter da ist
und deswegen sehe ich jetzt nicht was
eine demonstration solle habe das gas
nicht persönlich bei schaffen können und
ich bezweifle auch dass die aufgabe von
funktion dazu führt dass mehr gas fließt
wir nur ein letztes argument es gibt
drei pipelines von russland nach europa
zweieinhalb staffeln sind schon
weitgehend auf null gefahren es ist
nicht die nordstream 1 das ist ja mal
dies auf null die durch die ukraine
fährt ist deutlich heruntergefahren und
die seriös pipeline im süden ist auch
stark heruntergefahren das heißt es
nicht so dass hier deutschland heraus
gesucht wird oder hiermit ein spiel
getrieben wird es ist eine strategie der
russischen regierung gas als hebel als
waffe einzusetzen und damit wir die
verbliebene zeit noch nutzen können
möglichst viele zuschauer zu wort kommen
zu lassen jetzt noch schnell zu georg
fehrenbacher aus konstanz sehr
fehrenbacher hallo ihre frage bitte
an die runde ich hätte eine frage
letzter werten die ukraine nicht im
regen stehen in dem nicht die warten dem
umfang geliefert werden wie sie
gebraucht werden
an den ärmeln bitte herr cornelius sie
sind auch hier gefragt da ich gerne
weiter
nicht ausreichen und das ist genau
dieser zwiespältige
beobachtung die man auch mit blick auf
die eu hat oder auch selbst auf die usa
die deutlich mehr tun könnten obwohl sie
schon sehr viel tun der panzer deal
wurde angesprochen der ringtausch
ständig funktioniert es ist überall
diese zögerlichkeit da also seine
prinzipielle unterstützungsbereitschaft
aber faktisch wird es zu zäh oder
überhaupt nicht umgesetzt vielleicht
auch eine der kollege und sanktionen und
waffenlieferungen müssen hand in hand
gehen natürlich wir haben in der
diskussion darüber zu wenig gesprochen
aber das ist so dass beides zusammen
natürlich wirkt und schneller wirken und
teilen sie den eindruck dass die
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen
vielleicht für einige aus deutschland zu
zögerlich sind zu wenig den eindruck
muss man bekommen wenn man die
öffentlichen debatten verfolgt und die
erklärungen der bundesregierung
noch jemand aus der runde zu dieser
position helga schmidt ja also ich finde
es auch richtig dass international zu
sehen natürlich würde sich der
ukrainische präsident mehr waffen
wünschen aber es hat einen grund dass
kein nato-mitglied keines von 30 panzer
westlicher bauart liefert das ist nicht
nur deutschland dass das nicht tut kein
land will das ok das hat sicher etwas zu
tun mit der sorge vor eskalation ja
vielen dank für diese antwort auf viele
fragen unserer zuschauerinnen zuschauer
zu hören zuhörer das war der presseclub
nachgefragt ihnen noch einen schönen
sonntag machen sie es gut bis bald
[Musik]